my name is Joel wood I'm a youtuber and
a voice-over artist and I'm living in
London I'm from Hong Kong and I'm an
Olympic swimmer my name is Matilda I am
a university student and I come from
Italy my name is Kayla Lim I'm a
journalist at the Korea Herald which is
a daily English newspaper in South Korea
we are Deanna and Phil Deanna he is from
the United States and I full am from
Germany if everyone my name is Nathan I
am a musician and actor from Singapore
my name is Nico I work at bath to Japan
and I love inside you my name is Pedro
Rivas I'm an industrial engineering and
I'm from Spain here in Italy we are not
allowed to go out except for really
important reasons such as going to the
supermarket so should the same thing has
definitely become a thing in Singapore
people are less social streets are less
crowded hands are less shaken and people
are just generally a lot more aware of
things like physical contact I am still
going outdoors cuz I have a
six-month-old puppy and she needs
walking but I was staying clear of
people and I'm limiting how much I'm
going out I've been working from home
for four weeks now it's almost been a
month in the beginning it was because I
met with a friend with Ben today poo
where our first cases of group
infections started to occur the company
thought I should work from home I mean
quarantine is not Sunday night when the
Spanish government said nobody could go
outside unless they needed to go to the
hospital or grocery shopping my whole
family are staying here at home in
Germany there's no complete quarantine
yet
however we are kind of socially
distancing ourselves from other people
by almost staying inside the entire time
we started our active social distancing
from mid-february
I've been social auditioning for almost
two months now I personally haven't gone
out much
there's police and military raiding the
streets to make sure nobody is outside
unless it's strictly needed and this is
why all the streets are empty the number
of new cases in South Korea has been
going down but because this is a global
pandemic we're giving more attention to
incoming passengers who might be
potential carriers businesses are
suffering very much Germany was
categorized as high-risk and a lot of
the schools have been closed for the
next five weeks
a lot of the borders have been closed or
being heavily monitored everything is
just a little empty streets supermarkets
airports public transportation Singapore
is a very small country and we're very
very densely populated but I think the
government has been doing a fairly good
job of containing it for some context
we've been going through this since
January and since February Singapore
implemented its second highest public
alert system regular temperature
screenings at most public places it
fluctuates of the news cycle if the news
is good supermarkets are well stocked if
the news is bad I don't have toilet
paper to wipe my butt with the situation
started in the end of January in Japan
so that has me almost 2 months things
got pretty serious now to say the
situation in Japan is slowing down
people are pretty much back to normal
routine also the restaurants and shops
are open but only shorter business hours
the situation in Italy is quite worrying
there's no one around and streets are
completely empty I think Hong Kong is
doing pretty well and containing the
virus I'd say this is from a huge
collective effort if you walk on the
streets you see like 95% of people
wearing masks SARS happened 17 years ago
they're very aware of the consequences
of this virus nowhere is on complete
total lockdown here in the UK but that
is due to change fairly soon they're
advising social distancing and staying
at home as much as possible and for
those in at-risk groups which I'm in one
of those groups because I've got asthma
we're being advised to stay indoors for
12 weeks it feels a bit extreme but if
that's what the government advising and
that's what my doctor's advice then I
feel like I need to be taking it
seriously
I am pretty calm at this point but I see
so many news around the world every day
and I feel that Japan is a bit too
normal which makes me feel worried that
what if there's a spike of numbers of
infections in a few weeks again I am
very concerned for my family my parents
back home in the u.s. we don't know how
bad things will get in the end I'm
trying to be careful but not fearful
just living out each day the uncertainty
of what's going to happen in the future
is making me feel more anxious and
stressed I try not to think about the
situation all the time I always feel
like this situation is unreal I am
relieved that the numbers are going down
in South Korea but I'm worried about the
situation abroad we all share the same
earth the fact that I have not been
infected yet that's another thing to be
grateful for trying to stay positive I'm
holding on because of my cat I'm feeling
fine I am in an at-risk group I have got
asthma so I have been to the doctors
stockpiling my inhalers because I am a
bit worried about that even if I have a
common cold and I've got a blocked nose
I start to panic the thought of getting
respiratory issues if I was to get
coronavirus really does scare me I think
I'm feeling good but I think that's
partly because I've only been at home
for three days so far in two or three
days the situation is gonna be
completely different and we're gonna be
craving to go outside also at first we
were not scared at all about the virus
because they told us it was like a flu
but now it's been proven that it's not
like a flu so we are a little scared and
this situation is like a little
overwhelming I'm not gonna lie it's a
little bit scary undeniably a bit weird
because everybody is just a little bit
tense in times like these it's best to
remain hopeful these things usually have
a different to start and hopefully God
willing a definitive end
I can no longer go out I can no longer
go to university meet my friends good
regimes those do to go on a big family
holiday to Florida which is our first
full family holiday with all my family
members that's been canceled we can't
sort a lot of travel trips my grandma's
in a retirement home and that retirement
home is on lockdown no so no visit tests
I'm wearing masks all the time and
everybody I see I only see their eyes I
finish my phone calls always saying that
I'll see you when coronavirus passes
when this is over the virus has been
taking over almost every aspect of
Singaporean life every social media page
every single news article is it's pretty
much coronavirus 24/7 it's a little bit
scary when it's all you hear about at
first it didn't have any effects of my
life because people in Spain nobody
would like be bothered about the virus
but now we discovered it's a bigger deal
than we expected even though it might be
sunny and I lived right next to the
beach I can't leave my own house Hoos
are close gyms are very limited I've
been to Rio Olympics and I was thinking
that Tokyo Olympics could be my last
I was also planning to try out for
qualification meets and schedule in
March and April but most sporting events
either got postponed or cancelled which
I wish is fine my only wish is that is
pandemic will go away soon I'm willing
to drop everything right now and to be
part of the measures to contain this
virus and that's what it takes
[Music]
I've been washing my hands more than
ever I'm trying to avoid as much as I
can human contact or touching stuff I
wear gloves when I go outside and a mask
well not anymore because I can't go
outside I try not to go to busy places
and be careful the times when I use
public transportations I carry around
head wipes wash my hand and gargle when
I get home every time I've not been
getting public transport for the last
week and I haven't been to the gym for
about five days now my gym hasn't closed
yet but I'm not taking the risk while
this is going on I've been washing my
hands as advised by the government and
trying not to touch my face I touch my
face all the time but yeah the main
precaution I've been taking is just
social distancing I've been washing my
hands a lot more a lot more any time I
catch myself touching my face I have
like a little mini freakout and I need
to go find the nearest washer my phone
my shoes every time I come home I take a
shower
immediately and toss my dirty clothes
into the laundry I only go out once a
week to buy food when I come home I make
sure to wash my hands properly and to
disinfect the products that I use when
we were traveling back from Spain we
were wearing these masks on the plane on
the airport and on the train people gave
us weird looks but in the end I don't
think we regret doing that so my daily
life right now is pretty much just
confined in these four walls
I am currently thinking about going back
to Hampshire where my parents live in a
much bigger place with a big garden so
my dog can run around I've also been
baking a lot and that's why I'm worried
about getting fat because I just keep
baking
I'm trying to keep myself really busy so
I try to wake up early I work out here
in my house I study I feel videos for my
YouTube channel I cook a lot of food I
started doing more cooking at home and
talking on the phone to show the
situation of course only shopping and
I'm a big fan of sports and running so
that was something I used to do a lot
now I exercise at home in the treadmill
or playing table tennis with my brothers
but it's definitely very different to
what I used to do honestly know what'll
be different because I'm a bit of a
hermit anyway the work that's been
keeping me the most busy and most of
that can be
online I've been watching a lot of
Netflix I've been cooking I've been
annoying my cat I've been reading more
just finished Margaret Atwood's the
trilogy book on the end of the world
with the virus we work on our computers
so we're just working on our computers
at home now we'll watch a couple of
topic related movies until a week ago I
was working as an engineer intern in an
airplane manufacturer since interns are
not really an asset for the company they
counsel or the internships so now I'm at
home it is scary being self-employed
because I don't have the protection from
any of my employers the voice-over work
has completely disappeared I can't
survive on my earnings from YouTube so
I'm very lucky that I can keep making
videos I am so confined to just doing
videos in my bedroom but yeah my daily
life hasn't changed that much I'm just
going out for house a lot less as a
journalist I go go around
I am eat so many people usually but now
that I do all of that there are
messengers or calling this table is
where I work we are allowed to work from
office but many of them work from home
right now and if I do go into the office
I tried to avoid the rush hour meeting
wise we talked over video calls with
clients my university closed a month ago
now I have lessons online I'm trying to
maintain my routines as much as possible
because I know that this is really good
for my mental health as a performer
there have been a lot of canceled events
a lot of canceled shows a lot of
canceled shoes it's not too bad though
because a lot of the work that I do can
be done online and I can just record at
home but I kind of missed it
I really miss before me
now I have more time for other passion
there really been enjoying Wing Chun it
helped me physically to get into shape
but also it just keeps me mentally
grounded my aim for this year was to get
better at Spanish I downloaded a
language learning app and I've been
using it daily I've always wanted to
brush up on my Chinese and that's what
I've been spending more time on recently
I have been learning German and taking
some online courses related with
engineering I've heard that tick tock is
really trending right now so I will
probably learn some new tick tock tenses
I learned to dance on tick tock but I'm
not proud of it I've probably ingrained
some very very useful hygiene practices
future me is grateful for that I've been
trying to learn German this year so I've
been reading a lot of children's books
and German to Phil yeah cooking
definitely increased at that for the
cooking skill I'm learning how to cook
new dishes and I'm very glad of that we
should think of this situation as an
opportunity to do the things we always
wanted to do the first thing I would do
is go to the gym since well but I also
want to give everyone I will go for a
run at the beach because right now I
really miss the beach in the ocean and
running outside and of course I will
hang out with my friends since I have to
stay at home I can only see my family
which is not too bad but I could also
see my friends you know go enjoy spring
talk to people and just normal things
without the fear of piranhas I will go
to my apartment in Milan I will see my
friends and I will have them because I
really miss them I will go out to eat
and I will walk around the city centre I
would like to go outside without a mask
and I'd like to go meet my grandmom's
we wanted to visit the Anna's family in
the United States were uncertain if this
can happen or not so when that period is
over we will definitely immediately
start planning our trips travel is
probably lasting or anybody's minds
right now but once all this craziness is
over I'm gonna start finding some travel
I think it's crucial now that we take
care of both physical and mental health
move your body because I think if you
can stay active
you will stay sane for a longer period
of time try not to panic and try to keep
yourself busy spend quality time with
your family and finish all the Netflix
series that you have to watch Frank view
this is an opportunity to learn a new
skill or do something different people
are going through the same thing more or
less called them all awesome how they're
feeling how their day was stay informed
stay vigilant stay healthy inside and
out even if you yourself think you will
be fine
just think of other people's health and
safety you might carry the virus and we
have to be very careful of that thank
you seriously this will only work if
we're on this together no matter where
we come from
don't let the negatives take over just a
beautiful world I'd like to hope that
mankind is capable of overcoming a lot
of things there's always a bright side
in everything we do is stay strong and
things will get better we'll get through
this together
[Music]
[Music]
you